we're gonna see if he can sleuth out
the truth in drew confessions
[Music]
this is the first time we've done this
craig thank you for playing along
um all right pretty impressive i very
much like
the the uh the title sequence
did you make that in an app
we have amazing graphic people here at
the show
very good oh thank you craig well okay
so we have three musicians in our
audience
quinn in philadelphia hi quinn dorothea
in south carolina hi dorothea and
maclean
in gainesville florida hello hi guys
they all have musical talents one plays
bagpipes one
tuba and one is a rock drummer and we
have to figure out who plays what and if
we guess correctly
we get to hear some beautiful music
craig you go first
what's your question for the three
musicians to figure out who plays what
okay i'm going to uh do i ask each
musician a question each or just one
question for all three musicians one
question for all three all right here's
my one question for
all three um
what do you call someone that hangs out
with musicians
quinn nobody
no a wannabe i mean
good friends honestly
audience oh actually the correct answer
the correct answer is a drummer a
drummer is someone who hangs out with me
yeah you guys are like i i i
i got some information there do you see
that the reaction to the questions
that's what you're looking for
of course i'm just picturing none of you
at a trashed hotel room
um okay i'm gonna take another i'll take
a turn
what would people say if you brought
your instruments to a party
please leave please leave oh interesting
dorothea get it girl
okay
my friends would probably ask why did
you bring that
huh okay well gosh craig we have to
guess now
what do we think i got it i i got it i
i think uh i think dorothea is the uh
will i say
yes i'll guess all right i think
dorothea you're the tuba player am i
right
no see i knew you i knew that was
all right um
i think um mclean you play the bagpipes
that's right oh my gosh okay
um all right craig you have dorothea
and quinn to guess tuba or drums
um i'm gonna say dorothea is the drummer
because she doesn't play the two i just
deduced that in my head too
[Applause]
all right so now we know um
i love it okay well that was the first
time we played this game
um and i thank quinn and dorothea
and maclean for playing along with us
and
speaking of playing along as we go out
into commercial break will you please
play some music
i'll uh get your instruments ready um
please and thank you and craig i just
want to say
that it has been such a pleasure to
speak with you
you're someone i have look up to someone
i've loved
as a viewer and a fan and now being in
this seat
it's really wonderful to talk to someone
who is as versed and talented as you are
in it well thank you very much i think
that you are
very very talented you're having your
show will be a massive success
and i hope that you keep your feet on
the ground when you're
uh rocketing past all other hosts
to receive the nobel prize for talk
well and let's keep talking shel
silverstein
wonderful you know environments uh the
changes of life in the world and how we
navigate them
in these positions and thank you so much
and i love the hustler
um it's just a fantastic show and it
airs thursday at 10
9 central on abc it's a very fresh
concept and it's super awesome
and um i wish you the very best with
that
thank you drew you're very very kind
thank you for thank you for having me on
your show it's very nice of you i feel
the exact spot
[Music]
you